this episode of congratulations episode
44 is brought to you by a movement look
we get it holiday shopping can be tough
but thanks to movement all the
gift-giving anxiety can disappear with
the press of a button these watches make
the perfect purchase for just about
anyone in your life guy or girl and
remember they only start at $95 so I'll
let you know more about this later on in
the show but get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
MVM t.com slash Congrats
this episode is also brought to you by
the cash app everybody the babies are
switching to the cash app and it's the
number one finance app in the App Store
they've introduced the cash card a new
black debit card that you can design
yourself via the app allowing you to use
the cash you keep in the app anywhere
you want plus it's the best way to pay
people back download the free cash app
for iOS or Android now sniff everything
you know that's so cool that they have
their own [ __ ] like humans don't do that
humans just kind of give people the
once-over by looking and stuff right now
one dog is sniffing the other ones
[ __ ] and that's weird because they
know each other's [ __ ] already like
they've lived with each other for six
plus years and they're just sniffing
around man they're sniffing one fires
backpack but yeah we're here have you
downloaded my app yet you got to
download my app because it's bet I
actually meant to post a video of me in
one fire but I got to do that later and
get in the App Store Chris D'Elia
hey Sam come here what's up now you're
on the video podcast so yeah I'm here
I'm sniffing the [ __ ] microphone
ridiculous
sniffing everywhere
save me small bad dude your keys breath
smells so bad it's like and then they
were like hey well you got to remove
some of their teeth and they won't your
breath won't smell that bad and I was
like how much is it and they were like
oh so [ __ ] $7000 [ __ ] you talking
about do I get meals with that all year
long
give me meals with that all day all day
all year long
you know why sorry I sound like Foghorn
Leghorn I've been in Los Angeles a
last-place I was still Ohio and I'm
chilling I was at the Comedy Store a few
nights and I'm feeling good my back
hurts
it's all good that's gonna just how it
that's how it is for the rest of my life
this is how it's gonna be the rest of my
life when you get into your 30s you do
[ __ ] like pull your back and immediately
think okay well that's just how it's
gonna be the rest of my life like you'll
pull your back it'll happen and then you
go like this cool that'll be with me
forever like it's a [ __ ] child and it
sucks it sucks fat donkey dicks because
you're just like alright let me add it
to the [ __ ] ailments I have now and
that's how that's how it is now in the
1200s if you did [ __ ] like tore your
[ __ ] ACL guess what now you you're
[ __ ] you're just gonna be the guy that
you got to be the guy in town that
everybody goes to because you ain't
going anywhere bro you're getting two
pieces of wood and your and your and
your tying them up around your leg and
then you got to walk with two pieces of
wood next to your leg and and you and
you got dirty cloths time and tying and
tying them together
no casts butters leave them [ __ ]
alone leave him the [ __ ] alone
so yeah so but now even now we still
have [ __ ] like that and even though it's
2017 and and robots are jumping up and
down on platforms you saw that [ __ ]
thing that went viral
with the robot did a flip oh how did it
how did that happen remember when robots
were walking all jerky the week before
and then all of a sudden a video came
out
we're a robot did a flip how did we miss
that so quickly how did we go from jerky
robot and then somebody tweeted we dead
you know so drastic and then Elon Musk
is it right I always want to say Elon
gold there's a comedian Elon Musk said
this is nothing in five years we'll only
be able to see the move so quickly that
we only be able to see it with strobe
lights which confused this [ __ ] at
everybody because what the [ __ ] does
strobe lights have to do with anything
but yeah robots do flips now hey robots
do flips now robots that look like
humans do flips now and land they can do
that I can't do it I'm a human dude it's
crazy when you see this video they do a
flip and oh well what the [ __ ] was that
one I like when they [ __ ] up dude when
robots [ __ ] up it's the best yeah they
do flips now so and I got to have back
pain how about that
robots jump on [ __ ] platforms do
flips and I got back pain for the rest
of my life
cool catch you later catch you later
life hey robots are winning catch you
later life sayonara we're all dead I'm
gonna have back pain when I do lunges or
if I just sit in a chair too long and
robots are doing backflips off platforms
sayonara life
I mean we're dead I think we're the last
generation how about that we are the
last generation to just that's going to
be chilling and not gonna be the the RET
when I have kids those kids gun die
those you know what they're gonna die
not naturally by robots or the sun's
gonna explode or some [ __ ] or a nuclear
bomb I'm trying not to [ __ ] bust up
in women so I don't get you know babies
cuz I don't want them to have to [ __ ]
be cold all the time because the sun's
gone you know
the dark ages are coming and I don't
mean to sound like Alex Jones but the
dark ages tip part to our common man and
you [ __ ] up in Attica D listening to
this podcast had a kid last week guess
what your son or daughter is gonna be
real cold soon and robots are gonna be
doing backflips tearing their heads off
now sorry but that's how it is it's not
my fault robots are doing goddamn
backflips but I was listening to a TED
talk or some kind of Ted arrow radio
hour and they were like don't be scared
this is how technology is and there's
good and bad we just need to learn how
to [ __ ] live with it but I guess
that's true you know whatever as long as
I don't have to [ __ ] live by like I
tore my meniscus once 10 10 years ago
and it's all better now and if I list if
I lived in the 1100s I'd still have it
like this I'd probably be [ __ ] I'm 37
I probably look 46 46 or 50 dude people
look horrible I can't believe there's
people out there Luda like I know you
know I [ __ ] talked about this I work
out and stuff and I I try to eat healthy
although I ate [ __ ] 8 cookies last
night bro I couldn't they were so good
and I just kept beating him and the
butter was so good and every time I'm
eating here's the thing - I ate 8
cookies and it was 10 minutes of
pleasure and now I feel [ __ ] awful
and it's hours and hours later on it's
the next day
and my stomach is all [ __ ] that's
another thing that didn't happen when I
was 21 but now I feel [ __ ]
and I'm eat and I ate 10 cookies ray ate
8 cookies and and I I feel like not like
I ate ice cream a week ago and the next
day I tried to do my treadmill [ __ ] that
I do I do the intervals I go on for
level 4 and then 9.2 and I switch it
every minute for 30 minutes and daddys
[ __ ] dripping wet by the end by the
end I look like I was in
war and my [ __ ] hair is all over my
face and I look sexy as [ __ ] dude I mean
I look so sexy cuz I'm sweating and and
my hair is in my face and I and I look
sexy and if I was the thing if I wasn't
at the gym
I'd be real sexy but you're at the gym
so you don't look sexy at the gym you
don't look sexy at the gym but if if you
put regular outfit on me outside or
something with like jeans on and I was
sweating that much like throwing wood
into a [ __ ] back of a van or like a
truck and a girl walked by she'd be like
ooh
but because I'm at the gym and
everyone's doing that and there's fat
slobs and also weird moms doing the [ __ ]
that like they see me and they're like
that's just a guy sweating at the gym
that's gross but bro put me in a [ __ ]
field with like a flannel with no
sleeves on like if I'm dressed like
Kevin Costner in a perfect world and I'm
sweating that much forget it dude you
drive by you get Prag if I'm to picture
me in a field dripping wet hair in my
face sleeveless flannel shirt dressed
like Kevin Costner in a perfect world
and a girl drives back picture her not
getting Prag she stop it she's turning
round and I'm plunking so what I'm doing
we gone bobbing for babies
steady plunk in man for real but you put
me in a gym in the [ __ ] terrible
sweat shorts I have and a [ __ ] some
swag shirt I got from like some [ __ ]
company that gave it to me for free cuz
they want me to wear it out but really I
just wear it at the gym and girls don't
ever want to get hit on at the gym
talked to any girl
they never want that's the last place
they want to get hit on is the gym you
know where that's like hitting a
on a girl in her house when you're not
invited because they're just so
vulnerable and they're doing what
they're doing hey guy stop hitting on
girls at the gym I know it's hard cuz
some of these girls come with [ __ ]
full makeup like they're going out to
light or something that was a club in
New York in like 1999 all rights in
vague if there's one in Vegas maybe I
don't know or maybe it's not but if
there isn't there is a club name light
you know limelight I think it was in New
York but anyway yeah dude these these
chicks come out will come up to work out
with the titties out with the cleavage a
mess dude I literally saw a girl the
other day that came to the gym and was
walking around in like a bra that a
[ __ ] hooker would wear in a brothel
in like the wild wild west
it was silk and her her titties were
bouncing around and it was so weird and
she was just like she was dude you could
tell in her head she was like whatever
I'm a woman and this is what I wear and
don't hit on me you know I mean like the
powerful women that that's like this
[ __ ] right now
where it's like I can wear what I want
and you can't look at me and she just
got tassels on that [ __ ] cratenbarrel
what you know what and she's just got
tassels on and a [ __ ] dog collar and
the entertainer and no pants on but her
her pussy's painted like how Sports
Illustrated did in 2004 when they did
the painting bathing suits and she's
like what I can't wear what I want
without you staring and her pussy's
painted with like a [ __ ] and it says
enter here with arrows pointed to her
[ __ ] fried butterfly what with a dog
collar and with with a hook for a what
and she's literally on all fours what
I'm trying to buy pottery
but it says enter here yeah exactly
for whom I choose but your pussy's not
covered by fabric it's painted what and
we got to be like oh yeah so anyway I'm
just in line I'm just in line at at
Pete's coffee eyes up here but your
bento eyes up here but your titties are
hanging hanging out the bottom of your
titties are hanging out so yeah what the
[ __ ] did I got so darrell i got s said
the railed anyway it's so funny dude
like we can't even be like help us out
you know weird guys and our [ __ ] mid
ray or mid brain reacts so fast and it's
like help us out you know please help us
out ladies please like you don't have to
you can do whatever you want but please
please help us out it's hard it's hard
if you see a beautiful woman
there's nothing guys can do you see that
woman and you go damn you can't help it
and that's what makes babies you know
that's what that's what makes babies so
I'm asking help us out wear whatever you
want alright help us out but if you
don't don't get mad one time I walked by
a girl in Sacramento
doesn't matter where was but I checked
her out she walked by me and I looked at
her she was beautiful and this girl who
wasn't with her was walking behind her
and she goes ill gross give me a break
and I said ah [ __ ] you like that
if she couldn't get mad at you can't get
mad at me for checking someone out
because that's just how it's gonna be
cuz this house gonna be you know why cuz
we have [ __ ] brains that's why if a
[ __ ] red Ferrari drives by I noticed
that [ __ ] that's it
if you walk around with a doodle CUDA
when it comes to [ __ ] CUDA if you're
a guy and you don't [ __ ] all these don't
let the pendulum swing too far the other
way that's the thing man oh but it's
male toxicity you know toxicity and I
said hey and I said hey dude I love
I [ __ ] love System of a Down
they [ __ ] kill dude you know why cuz
that guy is so [ __ ] crazy and look at
his face and he [ __ ] did dude his
[ __ ] the way he I mean that's the
loudest singing ever of all time
and there's the toxicity ever said
Taylor said hey and then when he's like
wake up and he's talking to himself does
he say why did you leave your keys up on
the table and then answers himself and
says because I wanted to that's what it
is I don't give a [ __ ] if it's not that
that's what it is that's what he says
then I don't give a [ __ ] if he doesn't
say that that's what he says and those
are the best lyrics of all time period
chop suey you know they're [ __ ] so
good if you think system of a down is
bad [ __ ] turn round get out of the
venue turn round I would see like no
concerts I even saw my favorite tec-9 in
concert and everyone was bumping it into
me and people were in like army fatigues
and I was like the [ __ ] are we in a
dream let's get the [ __ ] out of here but
dude System of a Down the way his
look ago - where did the way his faces
go down down that left left the orange
one down Oh his face dude there's so
dope man I say t and our city and our
city do they still make music I don't
even know I just knew I mean they have
to you know but I love it all so cool
band name people have [ __ ] up band
name System of a Down cool band name but
like Death Cab for Cutie is that one
change it cab for cutie change it I mean
come on dude Sparklehorse was a band
name had change it uh Neutral Milk Hotel
it change it they just try to get three
words together that make no sense and
then you can get it by a guitar and
you're a band Neutral Milk Hotel hey
what should we do let's call it Neutral
Milk Hotel cool get a guitar and I'll
play the drums we did it now all of a
sudden we [ __ ] sold
we sold immediately when you think of
neutral Millcote well you think of a
[ __ ] three words together that have
no basis together or should have no
business being together and you buy a
guitar immediately you've sold ten units
already you've sold ten units then all
you got to do is sing a song and
immediately you sold a thousand units
sleepytime gorilla museum SIA
change it turn round I will enter you
now don't wanna but you don't want me to
therefore turn round decode the dunk
that's a combo dude sleepytime gorilla
museum hey you know what [ __ ] you
come on who is it for who's it for
System of a Down there you go
sleepy time gorilla museum change it Hey
also bands with full sentences gotta go
this is a bit this is a band name and
you will know us by the trail of the
Dead Sea yeah you can't have a band name
that would literally be a whole sentence
of good writing in Lord of the Rings and
you will know us by the trail of the
Dead Sea yeah
hey how about trail of the Dead
how about know us I don't even give a
[ __ ] that's stupid but and you will know
us by the trail of the Dead first of all
no we won't imagine that's how you found
out about a Dan a bed a bed a [ __ ]
band couldn't say it a band and you're
just like what's up with a [ __ ] dude
there's a little you know what you know
what I've noticed on this walk there's a
lot of dead people lined up in a row
have you heard of this band I mean I
don't even know that's not even a good
bit I don't know inner toxicity ever
said - yeah varsity dude and you'll
notice by the trail of the dead
how about [ __ ] bands that like my
cousin listens to like death metal or
some [ __ ] and we always tease them and
it's always like death death Punk or
death dead or death bed or and you will
notice by the trail of the dead and
they're just like waffles waffles
waffles waffles and people are just like
[ __ ] yeah dude bravo Bravo Bravo my dogs
are even looking at me confused right
now
and they're just like what is that music
for opera from prof. Rob Rob Rob from
society problem
like my dogs are [ __ ] growling my
dogs are are you metalheads Sam Roth
frog frog frog frog run of the system
profitable from from society
ruff ruff just it honestly just speaks
to us because you know we're all
comprised of conforming father from for
businesses from for dude those those
bands always have a song about corporate
businesses you know what I mean if
you're a [ __ ] frog form of corporate
minds problem for a man they make
another song about corporate minds dude
frog frog society for the father of
corporate minds problem for for business
ventures proper form lemmings frog frog
from sheep mentality from from from for
I just sold 10 units with that get out
of here you [ __ ] regular [ __ ]
[ __ ] from the floor from the
Starbucks ball perform the [ __ ] out of
here oh really
and then the chicks that are like pasty
white with tattoos I just don't go
outdoors from falafels
but still there's a song about worship
the Sun for four four four four then why
do you look like you haven't been
outside in 20 years you look dead you
look like you belong in the trail of the
Dead that the [ __ ] band named you
after for target from farfel farfel
farfel like-mindedness problems of sheep
mentality target no dude you know what
you're all trying to be the toxicity
adversity but you don't have the talent
to [ __ ] scream out that [ __ ] why'd
you leave you this is about the table
just wanted to wake up
I wanted to get rid of it from Johnson &
Johnson form of corporate Minds come
from Kaiser Permanente front of Rockland
Hamilton Beach blender front of like a
they talk about infomercials oh my god
you know get over yourself we're all
conforming if you're not conforming and
you're making up rules about not
conforming and then you got a group of
people conforming to stuff
guess what char basically come you
basically young come free conch you can
do what you want but that's what you're
doing
hey you in a band you got corporation
you got an LLC you incorporated guess
what you part Society you come just
because you wear black clothes and your
pasty white and you got a tattoo with a
[ __ ] site with a gun sight on it over
you know it doesn't mean you're not part
of the system
you come hey did you live out in the
woods in a log cabin
oh no you live in [ __ ] Greenwich
Village you comp hey dude do you live
next to the Unabomber even though you
can't cuz then you'd still be basically
in a in a society so you still do you
live 10 miles away from the Unabomber
but still in [ __ ] seclusion couldn't
think of the word was gonna say
collusion you still live in seclusion
hey dude it come are there for guys next
here do you form a band
and even though you're going off of
society for talking about how people who
like minded sheep you got four guys with
you and guess what you do you go to
another city and you sing ruff ruff ruff
ruff and you guys follow yet you come
you got Nell Elsie you're part of the
toxicity over city so bad yo if that guy
ever dies I want to be in [ __ ]
toxicity System of a Down oh man they
were the [ __ ] dude they still are
probably but that album that they had
like two three albums where it was just
like so [ __ ] 90s and they killed it
dude I know they are huge but they still
they should be recognized as one of the
greatest bands of all time [ __ ] you if
if you disagree turn around the dunk I
don't like any bands though period so
whatever it's how it is I just like I
don't like how people love me you know
what's the worse is like when people
think they were people love telling you
that they were fans of bands before
everyone knew that they were fans that
about the band they just love like oh
dude I was at their concert they were
playing for [ __ ] seven people at the
dime or some yeah it was a great it was
awesome nobody knew it was a free show
nobody came in and I was there and that
was when I was like this band is one of
the greatest bands of all time and now
they're Coldplay and you're like I shut
up dude you weren't there and you didn't
know you were facing the bar the whole
time trying to chat up a chick I was
there I was there dude they were
actually at my apartment
I had no idea the band was there and I
was the only one and I heard them and I
thought you know what this guy singing
frolf of a frother off this guy I knew
it was gonna be the next big thing and
now they're the band [ __ ]
what's that what's that band that goes
what's that one that's it was that one
you know that one you know that song or
no you have no idea what I'm doing
come on somebody out there knows it it
was so [ __ ] 1999 dude that's what
fuel fuel fuel that's what it is
where's the jam box bro yep what is that
song dude oh my god
fuel song the guy looks dope he's like
really he looks like he would be on that
song on that on that show Aeon Flux
don't want to hear it don't want to hear
the [ __ ] ads don't want to hear it
yes this song dude is some 90s
hemorrhage dude's a nineties guess if he
has platinum [ __ ] blonde hair and a
Anna Anna and his completely baby face
and then has a what do you call it a
necklace around with it just a black
t-shirt oh and an oh and guess if one of
the other band members has a large
button-down short sleeve orange shirt
there's nothing more 90s than a large
dude
[Music]
oh the fishbowl [ __ ] lens you know
what oh my my producer one fire tried to
Google fuel the band and it [ __ ] in
the 90s when you're like dude it's gonna
be amazing man we're called fuel and
people just Google fuel band and dude
will pop up immediately and everyone
will know us and follow us and then the
fuel band was invented and now all that
comes up is a fuel band that would be
like As I Lay Dying on the trail of the
Dead and then a [ __ ] movie comes out
that wins awards that's like As I Lay
Dying on the trail of the dead and then
[ __ ] the guys like oh [ __ ] man we
wanted that to be what they Google for
us and now it's a movie with [ __ ]
Kenneth Branagh and Naomi Watts and the
soundtrack is and no matter what you
google you can't find it we dead we dead
robots are [ __ ] flipping you know at
the end of that [ __ ] when they go higher
dude s and 90s to have platinum blonde
gelled downward hair and two earrings
and the necklace that DMX would have
with a black shirt and be skinny forget
it forget it it's the most 90s thing of
all time oh god that song rock though
dude
that song rocked fuel is a good name for
a band
there you go fuel there you go you know
what it is you know what you're getting
into you know already what I mean so
many wires in a music video you know you
know what you're getting into with this
band called fuel you know it's not gonna
be hip-hop you know there's gonna be a
guy with platinum
blonde [ __ ] gelled downward hair and
then another guy with terrible Heath
Ledger hair and enough short-sleeve
button-down orange shirt and you know he
plays a guitar because that's what he
does and you know Julia Stiles is in one
of their videos or some [ __ ] you know oh
my dog growled I don't think he agreed
with it but uh anyway oh and he's got
bell-bottoms
wow wow wow these guys are 90s but
anyway so uh [ __ ] man music is so funny
how they sing so hard and like nothing's
happening though like it's just there I
don't know I'm gonna do some ads here
here we go you ready movement you have
heard me talk about movement and I'm
sure you got yourself a watch now let's
finish your holiday shopping and get a
movement watch for someone on your list
move in watches start at just $95 at a
department store you're looking at 400
to 500 bucks movement figured out by
selling the online that they were able
to cut out the middleman and retail
markup providing the best possible price
such great prices movement watches make
wonderful holiday gifts too you could
buy like four or five of them for your
family it's great classic design quality
construction and styled minimalism over
1 million watches sold in over 160
countries get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
MVM t.com slash Congrats this watch is
really it is a really clean design and
it's sleek and it makes great fat a
great fashion statement now is the time
to step up your watch game go to nvm
t.com slash Congrats join the movement
babies go ahead and get a watch hey man
just stop petting him you know my
producer is doing the most one fire stop
looking at him don't make eye contact
he's making eye contact he's like Shh
Emma doesn't our god dude just stop
looking at him do people know how to be
around [ __ ] dogs you've got two dogs
yourself dude
one fire here's the deal man when when
when people come over and they're like
how come your dog's jumping on my shin
and they're like yeah the dogs gonna do
it because you pay attention to the dog
don't pay attention to the dog and the
dog won't pay attention to you dude
you can make it I contact with them and
the dogs like or don't make eye contact
I Drive no you know what my dog never
bothers me ever if I don't want it to
bother me you know why I look straight
forward I ignore the dog and the dog
feels like a [ __ ] for doing what he did
and then he [ __ ] travels on and
[ __ ] shits in the corner or whatever
the [ __ ] and then I get mad dude or you
go like this no or you straight on the
dog like you're [ __ ] Emmitt Smith
trying to make a touchdown you do that
[ __ ] to your dogs my dogs are over there
now because they know I'm [ __ ] Emmitt
Smith of the house you know who you are
another football player that nobody's
[ __ ] heard of ice I had to slam one
fire do it I had to do it I had to
[ __ ] slam on fire because of the
[ __ ] way he's making eye contact my
dog expecting them to be quiet you get
two dogs what if that's how DMX was he
didn't get it that would be my favorite
thing in the world if DMX was like hey
get your dogs off me and you're like bro
you got a no I bet there's a picture out
there Google if you google DMX I bet
there's a picture out there would with
DMX seriously a picture with DMX and 30
dogs I bet there is and I think that
that's funny as [ __ ] and you know he's
got his shirt off okay guy interrupted
in the ads but do it man
I mean look look what my dogs are doing
now he's did what I said and my dogs are
lounging like they're on vacation
they're not doing [ __ ]
and during the ads now [ __ ] movements
I'm gonna get mad because oh-oh was
happening while I was trying to [ __ ]
pitch watches here we go lift lifts
knows that drivers are what keeping them
moving
Laer literally ends drunk so they do
everything that they can to make sure
their drivers are happy on every trip
it's a simple formula fellas happy
drivers mean happy passengers
maybe that's why nine out of ten lift
rides get a perfect five-star rating
earn hundreds of dollars a week plus
tips earn more money drive more it's
never been easier to give yourself a
raise you work for yourself here babies
you keep a hundred percent of the tips
and they add up fast drivers have been
paid up to paid over drivers have been
paid over two hundred million dollars
since the features first introduced lyft
has even taken the guesswork out of
pickups the new amp device uses color
coding to help passengers and find their
drivers and passengers find their
drivers so join the company that
believes in treating its people better
go to lift calm / Congrats today and you
can get a $500 new driver bonus that's
5th that's lift calm / Congrats lift
calm / Congrats limited time only terms
apply now I got my words all jumbled up
because I was pissed off about the dog
thing still but lyft is awesome now what
you do is you go and you and you work
for lyft or you use lift to get rides ok
that's what you got to do it's easy they
color code their stuff so to do it my
dogs are lounge and like they're on
vacation babies stamps.com the holidays
are busy and I'm thankful that we have
stamps.com to help save some time
sending mail to our elders
stamps.com brings all the services of
the US Postal Service right to your
fingertips buy and print official US
postage for any letter any package any
class of mail using your own computer
and printer the mailman picks it up
that's what happens stamps.com makes it
easy they'll send you a digital scale
automatically calculates exact postage
stamps comm helps you decide the best
class of mail everytime print postage
any day any time Stan stamps comm is
always open 24/7 right now you two can
enjoy the stamps.com service with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital scale
with
long-term commitments go-to stamps.com
click the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in congrats that
stamps.com hit the microphone enter
congrats this is a full-time job man
I always think of that light line in
some rap song where it's like it's a
full-time job not to kill and he says
the n-word and I can't say that because
I'm white it's hard not to kill it's a
full-time job not to kill and he says
the n-word and it's like that's not
really a job how you do is don't have
guns mostly that's step one don't have
guns or any knives step two
don't do that it's a full-time job
really well first of all you're not
getting paid I get it I get it it's
poetry I get what you're saying it's
poetry but also don't do fuel bands
that's hilarious
I'd be like if they came out with
something called a Soundgarden and you
tried to Google the band and it was just
like new Soundgarden you have you want
to plant a garden with music and then
you play Soundgarden Warren's in your
Soundgarden but you're like what's that
song about the black hole Sun won't you
come won't you come
black homes home won't you come won't
you come and that smiles dude when I was
a kid the black hole Sun music video
almost made me release my bowels the
first time I saw it I thought why is my
anus getting loose it scared the living
liquid [ __ ] out of me it scared the [ __ ]
out me dude
black Oh some won't calm and they're
[ __ ] smiles dude that's so scary dude
oh the lady with the [ __ ] smile and
looking up at the [ __ ] hey how about
this it's so scary when the lady's
putting her lipstick on and the muscular
guys doing push-ups why why is it so
creepy dude how did they do that so
creepy how did they make the old people
just be so creepy smiling oh man and
he's got a Punisher shirt on it's really
screw it actually is still creepy damn
he was young why I actually had to turn
it off when I was a kid and that used to
come on in MTV I used to have to turn
off that video that's how scared I was
supply see still I would have [ __ ]
nightmare know when I was a kid I was
the scariest I was the scariest kid ever
when I was [ __ ] 12 bro even old when
I was 12 I was scared of [ __ ] I would
get so scared of everything my
imagination dude I would make stuff up I
actually don't even know if I've ever
seen this video all the way through cuz
I was scared but man I would be like I
know these images like if I watch a
black hole son I'd have these images in
my head then for like the next two weeks
of like scary people coming in my room
with their smiles and the girl jump
Ropin with her braces and and the other
girl putting ice cream all over her face
why is it scary nothing is even
happening it kind of has this
apocalyptic feel to it though you know
god what a good what a good music video
that is really like tonally and like and
like just creepy and scary god damn it's
good but yeah man I would get so scared
dude I couldn't even see Jason or Friday
the 13th or like Michael Myers forget it
with that white mask dude I could see an
image and I would be scared for months
my buddy Kevin Nelson would make me
[ __ ] watch that [ __ ] in his basement
well how come there's always that kid
that had like the lenient mom you know
and we and like you'd go over his house
and he'd be like let's watch porn and
you'd be like well and you'd be like my
mom doesn't care and you'd be like what
and you're just watching porn with your
buddy in his basement so weird and then
he'd get horny but then he shows you
traces of death and he's like drink this
and it's and it's like Jolt Cola and
you're like what is this he's like I
don't know my mom doesn't give a [ __ ]
you know like alright and you're
drinking Jolt Cola with a boner looking
at [ __ ] Friday the 13th and he knows
karate that guy always is like a [ __ ]
brown belt in karate and you're like
what what and you know my mom put me in
there to show discipline and you're like
discipline bro your bro what you you're
eat you're drinking Jolt Cola in your
basement in your basement with carpet on
half of it you know how East Coast is it
to have a basement first of all and then
with carpet on half of it and then the
rest of the [ __ ] is not carpeted and he
and he'd be like and he'd be like let's
have a karate tournament and you'd be
like I don't I don't know karate I mean
like I'll teach it but really he just
[ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of you
with porn on in the background and he
listened to [ __ ] like the band it
wasn't there it was there a band called
Nelson
that was his last name Kevin Nelson but
there was a band called poison like a
beep listened to poison I don't even
know what that band is or a Soundgarden
and Jason would be stabbing somebody in
their temple dude I [ __ ] I think in
all these bands now I don't even like
music but these guys butters come here
come here dude I like how you guys are
hanging out with me I'm talking about
the babies you guys are just listening
we're doing what we're doing and you're
being cool I got my dogs here they're
being very cool butters is being
annoying as [ __ ] I'll tell you that much
hey butters get stop [ __ ] growling
yeah there you go
now he's cowering like a little [ __ ] I
[ __ ] uh I saw an ad the other day on
like Instagram where it was like
celebrate all body types and and his
lady was in a swimsuit and and like
here's the thing
dude plus-size models great great that's
awesome there's a lot of plus-size
people out there but dude I saw an ad
where the girl looked like she was gonna
die in the next [ __ ] few years
because she wasn't healthy okay now I
know good celebrate your body whatever
but also we're getting a little too far
some of the people definitely have high
cholesterol okay and you got a workout
I'm not talking about the [ __ ] girl
what's her name who's like really
beautiful that has the millions and
millions of followers and everyone's
like yeah you go girl
cool do it great that's cool be your
body type she does work out a lot I feel
like too
she's you know why cuz she's got that
ass alright but some of these people are
like celebrate all body types
guys and girls I guess guys too and they
look like Jabba the Hutt hey man you got
to lose weight Samia or you gonna die
soon and you fams gonna miss
I'm not talking about the people at the
higher for ivory soap alright but like
let's be a little bit responsible about
it how about that how about you let the
[ __ ] pendulum sprint
swing the other way we're all [ __ ]
that's what I've been saying if you're a
[ __ ] true baby you know man
you let the pendulum you got to talk
about both sides man you can't
candy-coat the [ __ ] and be like all body
types and then you're on 600-pound life
all body types really can you stand up
not without help oh cool
your gun die alright cool
definitely pissed people off guess what
don't give thought don't give how about
post Malone when he was like what do you
say he said something about how hip-hop
or whatever what did you say about
hip-hop I tweeted about it if somebody
was people were slamming him about
hip-hop I mean my producer was gonna
Google post Malone hip-hop yeah that'll
come up he said he had a backlash
because what did he say post Malone
believes what is it that
I'll say believes there's not a lot of
real [ __ ] in hip-hop anymore that's not
it I tweeted it he said some about how I
can't remember I'm looking it up here on
my own Twitter Malone the European tour
doesn't make you cry dude like fine
better [ __ ] to complain about world this
[ __ ] you know oh yeah cuz he said he
doesn't listen to hip-hop to make him
cry he listens to Bob Dylan and and then
it people are like well there you go
another white guy just using the culture
to try and fun and then like slamming it
like hip-hop is isn't I like its roots
are from you know black people but like
there's so many the one of the coolest
things about it is that it's you got
[ __ ] like Asian guys in Japan rapping
- did you see the video about the Asian
girl thinking that the guy was rapping
and he was just giving an interview oh
god that's so funny and she was like woo
woo woo how Asian is it to do woo and
the girls isn't woo woo and the guy was
just like talking doing an interview and
she had no idea what he was saying
granny she didn't speak English not
really her fault and the guy was talking
like this because it was that [ __ ]
guy what it was the guy who has those
[ __ ] that guy yeah designer god damn
that [ __ ] song those songs but um
yeah and she thought he was rapping look
it up it's really funny but yeah post
Malone has used the culture and he is
hip-hop and he can say that I just
people and then and then on Twitter
it'll be like a Twitter moment people
bashing post Malone
and it's literally like [ __ ] seven
people who tweeted about it and then
just show it and then more people get on
board and then that's how it becomes a
thing Twitter moments is a thing that
isn't a moment and then they make it a
moment it'll be like people are outraged
at Taylor Swift's new dress and it'll be
likes for people to be like look at
Taylor Swift's new dress Wow and then
another guy will be like I don't see
nothing wrong with it
some guy in Michigan and then and then
everyone checks the Twitter story and
then it becomes a [ __ ] thing some of
these Twitter moments dude some of these
Twitter moments look I love Twitter fine
but some of these [ __ ] Twitter
moments dude look at them look I'm gonna
read some of them right now here's one
of a Fant well I mean these are all
alright the fan fave Walking Dead
character is leaving the show fine
you know that's sad I guess if for the
fan members or whatever but not really
because it's just TV show but here sunny
Leone gets sweet revenge on her crew
after their snake prank first of all I
know I don't know everybody but who the
[ __ ] is sunny Leone second of all what
snake prank third of all I guarantee the
revenge corniest [ __ ] fourth of all who
cares nobody and now Twitter put it on a
moment look even the moment has 33 likes
so who gives a [ __ ] look she's getting
revenge she put cake in a guy's face oh
cool that's none and now people are
tweeting about it yeah revenge amazing
oh dude
did we talk about that I talk about the
Justice League mustache yet oh my god
dude this is the thing that's the best
so justice so so Justice League came out
with a [ __ ] the movie and they wanted
to do reshoots now look here's the thing
I love those [ __ ] movies i watch them
but let's not pretend that they make the
most sense okay you've got a guy trying
to fight a super villain that none of it
makes sense they're [ __ ] going in
different worlds they're fighting
nothing makes sense Superman could have
saved the day in the beginning of the
movie but he didn't there wasn't even
kryptonite in one of the Man of Steel
movies that's the only thing that kills
Superman in like the first or second one
there was no kryptonite in it so you the
guys odd was just beating the [ __ ] out
of him and Superman was just like uh
getting the [ __ ] kicked out of until he
[ __ ] beat him so these movies make no
sense and that's not why you go see them
because you want a sound sensical
storyline sensible whatever the [ __ ] so
they did the movie and then the they
they were like okay we want to do
reshoots now look talk about a movie you
never need to do reshoots on is a
[ __ ] superhero movie okay my point is
cuz it doesn't make sense anyway alright
did you see Suicide Squad they
introduced every character seven times
the guy Deathstroke came in in New
Year's Ike yeah I'm Deathstroke Will
Smith and then it cut to Viola Davis and
she was like Deathstroke this is all of
his stuff I want you to know about this
guy government and this is what he does
and then you learned about Deathstroke
again with like another character
talking about him is like how many times
you got to know who the [ __ ] Deathstroke
is we know start the movie have him
shoot someone have him saved the day
okay so the fact that they did reshoots
on this [ __ ] movie anyway sia the
[ __ ] are
don't do it but they wanted to okay now
Henry Cavill or whatever the [ __ ] his
name is Cahill or caval never know if
it's a nature of e they wanted he was
shooting Mission Impossible sex now
Mission Impossible six made him grow a
mustache obviously because of course if
Henry Kate Cahill was going to be a
Mission Impossible 6 he would have a
mustache on because it just makes too
much sense so so Justice League was like
we want to reshoot this movie we need
Henry Cavill to [ __ ] have this to do
this scene and Mission Impossible 6 was
like it [ __ ] you he has a mustache he's
not shaving it because we need him now
now I saw people online they were like I
love how Mission Possible sticks with
their petty ass wouldn't let him [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's not petty as at all dude
Mission Possible 6 is now paying him 8
million dollars or whatever the [ __ ] -
[ __ ] act and keep this [ __ ]
mustache [ __ ] you Oh Oh Justice League's
wants to reshoot now oh yeah well we're
paying him 6 million dollars to keep the
goddamn mustache so Justice League was
like alright we'll [ __ ] CGI out the
mustache now here's the deal this is one
justice league should have been like
okay we'll either wait or won't reshoot
cuz the movie's not gonna make sense and
it goddamn way anyway because you got
five superheroes trying to fight a
[ __ ] bad guy and Superman would have
beat the [ __ ] out of them anyway no
matter what Aquaman or flash or whatever
so people are on the Justice League
thing and they're picking screenshots of
the movie showing you how bad it looks
and it looks [ __ ] terrible it looks
you know it looks like it looks like
someone's CGI'd out some guy's mustache
he looks like Shrek people are saying it
looks like Shrek people are saying and
it looks so not real and then when I saw
a post of it on Instagram
people were like honestly tbh I can't
even tell the difference
Hey Dude yeah you can
not a [ __ ] [ __ ] the guy's face looks
like it was made of clay and if you
don't think so
you're blind period you can't be that
stupid to think oh that looks normal
google it look at [ __ ] Henry Henry
cave those face CGI mustache just google
that and it looks like his face is made
of paper mache and that's what they
deserve that's what the justice league
deserved because you [ __ ] had to do
reshoots on a movie that probably didn't
make sense anyway that I would like
anyway even if it didn't make sense
also your movies gonna make four billion
dollars anyway why are you doing
reshoots
dude henry cavill is cool and I'm sure
he's I actually haven't ever seen him in
anything except for Superman which is
whatever but doesn't he just look like
the most on it on a date the most like
taking care of a [ __ ] chick s ever
doesn't he just look like a girl that a
guy that's like that he opens doors and
like pulls a chair out doesn't he look
like he just does that [ __ ] like in the
most boring way - not in a cool way
- where he's like oh let me get that for
you and you're like and the girls like
don't try my [ __ ] up you look perfect
just chill you're Superman you don't
have to [ __ ] do any of that stuff
okay don't do that stuff you know what
you drive puss huh don't do that stuff
and be chivalrous in your own way but
don't be the normal corny ass way
chivalrous dude girls don't like that
[ __ ] it's 2007 man if you're gonna do
that [ __ ] you got to have some tattoos
you can't just be a vanilla [ __ ]
that looks nice and pull a chair out and
here we go with the [ __ ] oh I like
that my husband did that's how he won
you bored in your life and you know it
let's wet it up let's wet it up five
o'clock shadow
Nick tattoo peeking out from the [ __ ]
crew neck you don't have to be like get
your own [ __ ] chair but you got to be
like here
there you go sit down wet it up wet it
up you're trying to get the seat wet Oh
pull out the chair there you go take a
seat let me get that for you see uh see
ya boring vanilla [ __ ] you better have a
[ __ ] tattoo of a compass on your
forearm
you better have a cool misfits tattoo
wet it up don't be someone with no
tattoos and take a chair out for a lady
don't do it with a nice crew you know
Henry Cavill wears crew neck sweaters
from j.crew wet it up get a neck tattoo
and you're fine dude get a neck tattoo
and you're fine I've never seen somebody
on screen more that would be 510 more
than Henry K Havel there's no way he's
not 510 I've never looked it up there's
no [ __ ] way he's not 510 and if he
isn't 510 I'll tell you what he wears
shoes to make him 510 and he's not six
feet if he's six feet he's always
standing in ditches
cuz he's 510 wet it up he's not 6-1
they're saying he's 6-1 on Wikipedia
there's no [ __ ] way
he stands in ditches then God he's
[ __ ] handsome huh but you know he's
nice as [ __ ] and it [ __ ] dries it up
you know if he was having sex and the
girl was like smack my ass he'd be like
okay
and do like a little bit chess there we
go yeah who knows I'm just making [ __ ]
up I'm just jealous cuz he's [ __ ] so
cool and Superman but that's how I am
but that ya do it
like come on hey how people would like
to do active in people like you don't do
enough activities [ __ ] that I'll just
think a Henry Cavill all day long I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
I'll think of Henry Cavill all day long
and be happy about it have you guys
tried saucy look I hate shopping for
alcohol because I don't know what I'm
doing so thank goodness for saucy
introducing saucy the alcohol delivery
app saucy delivers your favorite wine
beer and liquor right to your door on
demand it's like lyft for alcohol now if
you're in Los Angeles San Francisco
Chicago San Diego or Sacramento your
saucy order will arrive to your door in
30 minutes or less now that's quick
ready to drink for the rest of us
saucy will deliver beer wine and liquor
to your door in two days or less
nationwide alright you got a party going
on order it was saucy if you've got the
saucy app you've got a fully stocked bar
on your phone no order minimums no
delivery fees no run into the store you
get to chill in your home and for a
limited time you can get $15 off when
you download the saucy app and enter
promo code Congrats that's the saucy app
spelled sau cui and enter promo code
congrats for $15 off get the saucy app
today and use promo code Congrats Square
cash look all the babies and all the
people in McCulloch are switching to the
cash app I've talked to him it's the
number one finance app in the App Store
sending and receiving money is totally
free and fast and most payments can be
deposited directly into your bank
account in seconds Square cash doesn't
list your stuff in the feed I hate that
others other cash apps the app I'm
sending money apps they list what you do
in the feed and it's intrusive square
cash doesn't do that the new cash card
they have is very cool it's a black
debit card that you can design yourself
via the app the cash card allows you to
use the cash that keep in you keeping
the app anywhere you want you laser at
your card to personalize it and it will
be delivered directly to
for free you could put anything on that
on that cash card and it's very cool
it's an expressive thing to do the cash
app team is constantly building awesome
new features so what your so what are
you doing using the other guys get the
cash app today
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android and do it now
alright guys last one I'm gonna give you
a challenge okay find a gift that is
affordable practical and
instagram-worthy on the top of that list
is quip the electric toothbrush that
looks like it was designed by Apple
without the high price it's very cool I
have two of them and they're very sleek
and clip is the new electric toothbrush
that packs just the right amount of
vibrations into an ultra slim design
which guy with guiding pulses to
simplify better brushing at a fraction
of the cost of buck a buck a bulkier
brushes here's the deal - I used to use
some of these brushes not the quip ones
but the other vert like the you know
other companies and whenever I did it it
would make my gums where I have
sensitive gums these don't do that these
are have like the I don't know if it's
like the perfect amount of vibrations or
whatever but like they don't hurt my
gums and they don't get like red it
works I use it I take it on the road
quip electric toothbrush is featured in
just about every gift guide this year
like forbes GQ Oprah's o list and it's
backed by dentists hygienists
and dental students and dental
professionals quip starts at just $25
and right now you can go to equip you
can go to get quip comm / congrats to
get your first refill pack free with
quip electric toothbrush
that's your first refill pack free and
at get quip comm / Congrats spell GE tqu
IP comm / Congrats guys we've got a new
Elder let's just get right into it
we've got a new Elder she is great 11
ounce an elders because you know why it
helps us build our cult it helps us
understand who we are it helps us weed
out the Cudas and push them at arm's
length who is it
Margo at home girl marks why she made
this costume
you can see it on the video on the
podcast video for Halloween the CUDA
catcher we saw it on Twitter and we
liked it will DM you the details Margot
to get your pin and certificate great
job she dressed up as a COO to catch her
and I like that idea a COO to catch her
you know that's who we are
we're catching these Curtis catching
these kids and we did
we're catching Cudas left and right even
if we're not doing it with like actual
rope and tassels and like bars we're
doing it in our minds and that's how we
do it now we all got a little bit of
coot in US but it's about diminishing
that kuda find out who you are it's
freak punch do whatever you want go to
Coachella if you want but if you do
understand you killed it kuda true baby
true baby kuda you understand it's a
circle there's a [ __ ] wall there but
true baby kuda it's like the end of them
it's like the end of the [ __ ] movie
when you're like oh [ __ ] okay I get how
it's been the bad guys are the good guys
but the good guys are the bad guys too
in a way every TV show is trying to do
that now where it's like you know
everybody's good in their own way though
even though he's selling cocaine he's
like doing it for his family it's real
anyway
all right let's see ing I don't know if
I had a [ __ ] IG of the week [ __ ] it
been watching The Punisher you got to
watch my buddy Ben Barnes kill it on the
Punisher he's [ __ ] awesome I'm in the
middle of it so don't ruin it for me but
uh bombard Ben Barnes is my home he's
been my homie for a few years and this
dude does actually a killer [ __ ] in New
York subtle New York accent I told him
the other day and but because he's like
[ __ ] hardcore British he's not law
he's kind of British he's like like nice
like handsome like would be like like
girls would be like oh a prince you know
I give a please play like nine princes
he's on he was the Narnia guy and
Chronicles of Narnia you played the
[ __ ] prince whatever the [ __ ]
and he's plays the the guy and I don't
want to ruin it but the adversary and um
in the Punisher and yeah so that's
what's up violent show which makes it
cool and it's cool anyway and Jon
Bernthal I mean when they said they were
coming out with the Punisher I was like
oh Jon Bernthal is gonna be the Punisher
I mean there isn't somebody that's like
more perfect looking to play The
Punisher than him the only other guy
that could play it more is it was that
singer and Henry Rollins like he looks
like The Punisher but he's like the
older version so anyway it's a very cool
[ __ ] show and I have a feeling
they'll do nine seasons of it so what
else do we do usually the Twitter
questions we could start Twitter
questions and then bounce you got any up
here yeah I don't want to do that
[ __ ] we already did it with the other
one so what are your thoughts yeah I
actually thought about this
Keith Richardson's the Keith Richardson
at Keith Richardson nice not many people
have the actual analytic what
Oh No
Keith Richardson at rich key thirds sin
change it it's not cute
it's not cute you almost got me there
that's how quick and quick it was it's
interesting what the mind does when you
look at some [ __ ] coup de [ __ ] you
know tie mean what are your thoughts on
people who listen to headphones while
they drive yeah dude it's a death wish
it's the smallest death wish ever but
it's a death wish put on the radio how
about this put on the [ __ ] thing on
the Bluetooth in your car how about that
your radio doesn't work live without it
I get when people are just like oh I
need my music I'm just like no you don't
you need water you need food sit oh I
need my music though music is life Sega
what is this [ __ ] that this [ __ ]
guy's asking corduroy dad at corduroy
dad Krista Leah would you love corduroy
what even is that sentence would you
love corduroy what sure no I don't like
corduroy maybe a quarter or a jacket
maybe if it was real thin but like you
know when guys were those pants with
like a thick corduroys [ __ ] [ __ ]
with those thick-ass corduroys can you
still be Rodrigo GB change at change
sheet I get it cool can you still be
considered a true baby if you listen to
other podcasts like bill birnes or Joe
Rogan's of course no I have to be the
only [ __ ] podcast you listen to I
implore you to listen to those other
guys those guys are the best they're
buddies and they're the best
Malcolm Katzenberg at Mia Oh
Comex I don't know how old is too old to
go to a waterpark
I am nine I think nine but really
probably sixteen I would say then you're
just like the creepy what are you doing
hey back up stop [ __ ] growling dogs
all right well we're gonna wrap this
[ __ ] up man we had a good one we had a
fun one and we talked about you know
some good [ __ ] leave me on ham leave me
on here
you know and I just [ __ ] is are tissa
t-statistic and our city and I said a
movement get 50% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
MVM t.com / Congrats square cash have
you switched yet
download the free square cash app design
your cash card get it for iOS or Android
now subscribe to the YouTube channel and
watch the videos they are visual and not
just listening to it I get it if you
can't listen if you can't watch it or if
you like to listen to you in your car
but if you're at home check out the
youtube video channel that we do we
don't we got the you can watch the this
podcast that way watch your podcasts
that way and download the Chris D'Elia
app for iOS or Android and you can also
get some merch we've got the know CUDA
shirts we got the true baby shirts get
them holidays are coming
they're good holiday gifts to get your
your friends and family if your friend
likes to show subscribe rate and review
the show tweet me by using the handle at
congrats pod or whatever and video
episodes go up Tuesdays for Wednesday's
Irvine in San Jose coming up shows
upcoming shows to Crystal I'll calm
those were almost sold out eight your
San Jose tickets San Diego Riverside on
New Year's Eve join me drink some
champagne
Winnipeg Winnipeg Calgary Saskatchewan
and you can go on my website get all
those dates watch man on fire
incorrigible white male black comic
control my specials thanks for listening
guys have a good one baby sia the fog
Nara
[Music]